nobody knows for sure why the beasts
developed a taste for man flesh but
perhaps they simply figured that
compared to say an antelope humans were
about as difficult to catch as an
arthritic torus either way once they
went full human snack the Lions never
went back and they proved to be
frighteningly efficient human Hunters
creeping into the camps at night and
dragging men screaming from their tents
before devouring them under cover of
Darkness to begin with the attacks were
sporadic but as the Lions grew B ER they
came almost every night with each lion
dragging away a man to itself the
workers responded by building fences
made from woven Thorn bushes and keeping
fires burning throughout the night but
it didn't work the railway Tycoon sent a
couple of officials to find out just
what the hell was going on and they did
so in truly spectacular fashion because
within hours of their arrival one of
them had been killed and eaten by the
Lions and the other had lacerations all
down his back